Last Friday,
thousands of Arabs marched
through Essen's city center.
Loud,
all-work,
shouting through the streets,
huge flags,
strongly attached to the flags of the terrorist organization ISA
inside.
The streetscape marched is strictly separated
by gender,
the women are fully veiled,
Participants demand the proclamation of a Caliphate
In Germany
and German residents hardly dare to
on the street.
Just a few hours later,
1 more mob moves
of over 8,000 strangers
in a gloomy column through Berlin.
The famous neptune fountain
is climbed by several riots
and as usual in conquests
Palestine will
Flag placed on top of the fountain.
Cheering and cowardly foreigners,
Police and state in retreat.
Images,
going around the world.
And suddenly they seem
completely surprised by the CDU to the Greens.
Boundary crossing,
CDU deserts in NRW,
unacceptable sounds even The Greens
and Nancy Fehder barrel
gets upset about the crossing of red lines.
What hypocrisy,
when now suddenly the einwanderungsfanatiker
outrage in the Sunday rain,
ladies and gentlemen,
what does the traffic lights do?
What are all the prime ministers doing?
from höchst to Söder?
You all just today
tomorrow again state-supporting talk prevailed.
But Goethe summed it up so nicely,
it is enough not to want,
you also have to do.
And they do nothing at all.
The borders are open all over the country,
Migration is not stopped,
but disguised as skilled worker immigration
and continues to be cheered on.
Citizenship law is being streamlined.
German passports for all,
best first thing tomorrow,
before them.
So everyone gets artificially upset
and hypocritically outrage,
they should ask themselves the question,
who has these conditions in our cities
actually to answer for?
And that,
ladies and gentlemen,
they are,
that they have the immigration fans in all the old parties,
all those forces hostile to the homeland,
where 1 German Germany was always 1 thorn in the eye
Germany will change
and we are looking forward to it,
we still remember well,
that was their motto,
as the central question for the future of our country
was put.
To you Allen,
Germany could not and cannot be colorful at all
be enough.
And now Germany has changed
and out there,
marched under the flags of the Caliphate
her colorful dream,
their chatter of skilled workers,
of enrichment,
from uh integration and from the raketenwissenschaftlern.
All this finally dissolves into thin air
and behind remain the ruins of a left life lie,
for which they were all ready to sacrifice our country,
ladies and gentlemen,
German districts,
German districts
are now the places of retreat
radical Islamists.
The Caliphate's Army is recruited from
the ruler of unremarkable mass immigration.
And the treasure chest of the Caliphate
is in truth
German citizenship.
Their policies cannot find a solution at all,
because they are the problem,
the foreign country name on german streets
has not fallen from the sky.
It is the logical consequence
their crazy Einwanderungspolitik,
ladies and gentlemen.
And who now supposedly wants to solve this problem,
he can't address a central question.
Duck away,
in which Germany do we want to live
and whose Germany should that be anyway?
Almost 10 years after the welcome craze
from two thousand and fifteen
this question arises again
and this time even more urgently.
And it is becoming increasingly clear,
that there may only be 2 options in the future,
either
Chaos street battles and ethnic conflicts
in the colorful multicultural state
or in Germany as the country of German,
as a place of freedom,
of order and of normality.
And on this question,
ladies and gentlemen,
there is no compromise,
there is only 1 either or
and every single one here in the house has to decide.
If we don't massively counterattack now,
then we will experience a future,
which,
with the idea of a
self-confident liberal
and democratic
national state
will have nothing more to do.
This shows 1 look at any demographic statistics
and in every German newspaper.
That increases shows also
1 walk through every German city
and every trip by bus or train.
Today,
there are still 3,000 who demand the caliphate,
tomorrow maybe 30.000
or do we want to wait until there are 300,000?
Radical Islam in Germany in 2,023
quite openly the question of power
and we must answer these with all harshness.
The slogan of the hour is remigration,
and millions of times remigration.
Who now here but rumschreit and from remikation
doesn't want to talk,
who may be silent,
when the followers of the Caliphate
move through our streets in the future.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it shows itself once again with this topic.
Quite clearly,
only the alternative
for Germany is willing and able,
to make the clear statement that it needs.
With us,
there will be no caliphate in Germany,
but a rigorous verabschiedungskultur.
Because Germany is our country
and we won't let it be taken away from us.
Thank you very much!